retour en france avec cette grève à
nouveau des sages femmes elles demandent
une revalorisation salariale
l'augmentation de 500 euros annoncé par
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
ne leur convient pas elle la juge
insuffisante
depuis hier et jusqu'au 31 décembre
lohan ssf l'organisation nationale
syndicale des sages femmes appellent à
une semaine noire écoutez le témoignage
de celle henrique a délégué cftc
adhérentes de l'eau nsf elle nous
raconte son quotidien de sage femme très
souvent difficile
j'étais en garde jeudi la nuit de jeudi
à vendredi là
on a fait cet accouchement plus les
consultations à 3h femmes donc on avait
nos si enfin on n'a que cinq salles
d'accouchement plus la salle nature donc
six salles avec des patientes un travail
aux trois sages-femmes en gérant en même
temps les consultations avec deux
patientes quand même c'est nier plus
d'un litre
des nouveaux nés pour lesquelles on a dû
appeler les pédiatres
on sait pas à poser une seconde
c'est à dire même pas le temps de
prendre un café
de fait d'aller aux toilettes simplement
voilà huit heures quand la relève et
elle est arrivée quand on a pu passer le
relais et dont on a mangé notre pas de
la nuit parce que parce qu'on n'en
pouvait plus il nous fallait reprendre
des forces avant de pouvoir rentrer chez
la patiente qui a accouché en sa nature
aurait aimé bénéficier d'une péridurale
lui nos salles étaient pleines ce
n'était pas possible